like when Ali met Frazier for the second  time it was tense and vicious look at  Bill Clinton far worse minor words and  his was action Trump lashed out at Bill  Clinton while Hilary played the  rope-a-dope Trump had been rocked by  this tape from 2005 and his description  of his treatment of women while  Republicans fled the hardcore were just  as loyal and running mate mike pence  went to get ice cream governor what's  your reaction to Paul Ryan abandon a  Donald Trump today and those for and  against had a row about it Trump plowed  on as more women emerged alleging  inappropriate conduct I have been  contacted by women who allege  inappropriate conduct by mr. Trump while  he seemed to have forgotten when the  election is make sure you get out and  vote November 28 his chances on November  the 8th look pretty grim right now